[Music]
what
is something that you guys think people
glamorize
that is in reality very toxic
toxic everything
life um god where do we even
yeah damn i feel like every
concept known to man can be
[ __ ] up depending on who's
in charge of it so like so like you
could get every example right that's
supposed to be a beautiful thought like
an idea like it could be
religion or whatever right and you know
that there's a [ __ ] group within that
group that ruins it for everybody else
yeah and also i guess like the slice
that's presented
so when you think of like jordan and
he's like the greatest basketball player
maybe even the greatest athlete that
ever
lived and you look at that slice and
super glamorize like [ __ ] i want to be a
champion like that
but then he also find out that he didn't
really have time for his family or his
kids
or anything else everything was all
about him and what he wanted to do with
his career
then when he starts to like open up that
slice and you start viewing it you're
like oh [ __ ] is that what i want
yeah that's true or like ceos of
companies like
super successful people what did they
sacrifice dude he was known for that
like his kid lisa like he didn't really
know her very much
and he was a workaholic purposefully
said he she's not my daughter
[ __ ] you like for a long time maybe
maybe she was boring
yeah maybe she sucked yeah yeah so this
girl on tik tok
named a singer songwriter named naya
ford
asked that same question and she started
off with her own saying
when people say i want a significant
other who is rude and mean
mean and not friendly to anyone who the
[ __ ] says that
girl no one's gonna cheat on you it's
okay
is that is that a thing that people like
i want a dick ass husband
personally i've never heard that i've
never heard any
of my friends or anyone i want an
impolite boyfriend
but i can see like i want a boyfriend
who sneezes on me
and he doesn't say sorry is it like
saying like i want a girlfriend who's a
[ __ ] to everybody but it's a sweetheart
to me yeah
that's what you're saying that that's
why i was kind of like
trying to understand like maybe that's
what that means because then i guess
there's like possessive girls where
they're like i don't want my boyfriend
to
say hello to any other girl and like
that is rude is like not being friendly
to other people
so i guess that's what she means maybe
maybe these girls that say that they got
cheated on
too much that's why she's like oh yeah
that's why she's like girl no one's
gonna cheat on you yeah
it's like um yeah they are because
they've been right
but it's not even girls that do that
either it's like guys where it's like
they don't want their girlfriend to be
polite to any other man
look at that guy were you just looking
at that guy what are you wearing you
can't go out there looking like that
why are you doing that you disrespected
me yeah yeah
that's pretty [ __ ] toxic maybe it's
one of those deals where like
she had such a bad experience with
someone you know you always want the
inverse of the thing that just drove you
nuts
yeah so maybe her last thing was the
opposite of that [ __ ]
and she's like now i want the other one
the last one was so
[ __ ] friendly and polite he was so
nice
he couldn't say no to vagina that's how
nice he was
he didn't want to have sex with them he
told me but he kept
doing it damn because he's nice so a lot
of other tick tockers they started
sharing their own versions
and so this one says youtube couple
pranks so youtube couples who do pranks
they're so obvious that they're doing
pranks and they just get more and more
extreme with it
embarrassing each other on camera why is
it toxic
like prank versus prank that's exactly
the photo that they use
they're one of them they're one of the
legends
[Laughter]
don't tell them but i guess like people
that end up seeing that don't think it's
fake they start
doing it to their own couple like their
own they want to emulate them right and
it kind of ruins the relationship
right i probably think like oh that's
love when you prank each other
when the other person doesn't even know
i don't know well dude i like that
because nikki tries to scare me too much
so i'm in with that
you need to show that to nikki nikki
this is why
stop scaring me i'm afraid of walking
down a dark hallway i don't you're
traumatizing me right now
she's like around the corner dude she
gets [ __ ] her jollies man
yeah they're fun hiding behind we have
like the you know our bar in the kitchen
we got that or what do you call it an
island yeah island um
nikki loves hiding behind that and like
maybe a hallway corner or anything and
as i just come home or something and
walk in
she she just pops up goes ba and then i
and i always go
what
yeah that's what she says that he has
zero reaction is just
what it's not for content or anything
just oh that's even better
yeah this is just what we do with each
other well not with each other she does
it to me and that's what makes it
genuine though
maybe the filming part is the toxic part
it's just terrorizing them
but i mean [ __ ] man what's wrong with
having fun
so long don't start it don't [ __ ] yes
start it
scare him and eyes she rubs it in too
she like she'll scare me and then she'll
be like your face
it was like oh you guys are so toxic
stop perpetuating this toxic i really
hate it i don't mean to rub it in i just
it's part of the fun you scare me i
i don't like it that's fake because
that's way worse no no no jump scare
i would rather not make jump scares any
day than like some bad news that's not
real
holy crap she takes a month off my life
easily every time she does
but i do think it is kind of funny
afterwards
oh [ __ ] no but then it's cute because at
least isaac plays back with me you never
do
but you want me to scare you but he'll
hide too and then he'll be like boop and
i'm like oh
you got me baby you got oh see this is
why they say it was toxic
see see it's never ending it's just
revenge revenge revenge
oh yeah it's not revenge it's like an
ongoing game
true true fun but if you don't have fun
then i'm not doing it anymore that's why
i haven't done it in so long
i like scaring taika he goes you scare
me
that's [ __ ] cute the next thing is
disney movies
so oh [ __ ] them huh yeah so there's
three examples
it says snow white's stepmother paid a
hitman to kill her and when he actually
didn't do it she went to go complete the
job herself
cinderella's stepmother was so shrouded
in jealousy that she and her daughters
enslaved cinderella and tormented her on
a daily basis and her only option was to
get married to get away from them
ariel was so enamored by human beings
despite the fact that they murdered her
mother
that she went to a sea witch so she
could fall in love with this man that
she
just saw all right debbie the downer
[ __ ] you know what's funny is that the
disney movies
are they they made it
more friendlier when the original
stories that they told the children were
way more fun yeah these are cleaner
adaptations of like old
way yeah i know no wonder dude people
are looking at us now like yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] some of the king arthur
[ __ ] and like sir mordred and [ __ ] like
[ __ ] cutting heads off like
give me a break will ya it's kind of
crazy they're hyper analyzing fiction
i mean it's meant to be fiction yeah
it's meant to be toxic because it's like
the bad
villains that that's the villain in the
story that's being toxic right no it's
the
no it's the hero the the protect the
protagonist
or the for a little mermaid oh wait no
yeah look mermaid yeah that's toxic yeah
i can see
her desire to be with humans but then
like i'm like snow white
though snow white stay with your own
kind really yeah
yeah it's no way it wasn't her fault
yeah it wasn't toxic
yeah that makes perfect sense for the
movie to have a villain that's toxic
if the villain gets defeated right yeah
it's fine we'll go after their favorite
thing probably harry potter i guarantee
it
and they're like you know oh in harry
potter world like you get to go to this
super exclusive elite school where you
learn magic and nobody else gets to
learn about magic
they're all [ __ ] well you learn about
magic yeah they wanna they wanna they
wanna talk about yeah
super privileged and everyone else is
[ __ ]
dude this is a fun game let's destroy
everyone's childhood
let's get this our favorite thing let's
go favorite movie come on
back to the future oh so you can go back
in [ __ ] time
and you're so special you can change the
world why are you so [ __ ] better than
the rest of us
why didn't you take the homeless guy
who's sitting on the who's laying on the
bench
and help him improve his [ __ ] life
instead of marty mcfly trying to get his
parents to [ __ ]
yeah and then he
and he gets a nice truck afterwards
a sick ass truck proving that capitalism
is really the only thing that makes you
happy
[ __ ] back to the future all right next
toxic thing
is no new friends this concept of no new
friends we gotta cut that out you close
yourself
off from meeting people who could become
a better friend than the one you have
because
that friend is probably toxic well that
i don't know i don't know that's
assuming that the people that you have
is [ __ ] and you need to move on
that's true that's a huge assumption
that's a huge assumption
what about no new friends because i love
the people that i'm with right
now and it's like and it's exhausting
getting to know you yeah and it's like
every time you take a risk
and you have to learn and i don't know
like there's just
i don't get i don't know this is a weird
yeah no new friend seems like a figure
of speech
i don't think anybody actually really
they people people just say that to make
their current friends feel nice
like no new friends me and you for life
yeah and then and then they end up
finding friends
hi my name's tom i thought you said no
new friends
i don't know who lives by this yeah it's
just a great lyric
yeah yeah this next one the uh
the broken men can only be healed by
women trope
the idea that can only be healed through
the love and labor of a woman
this perpetuates the idea that men
cannot find healing or support from
anybody
except for women which is why they don't
seek it from their friends they don't
seek therapy they don't have connections
outside of their female partner to
support them
this obviously puts a huge burden on
women to care for men
heal them reh rehabilitate them and that
same energy is not given
to women so if you want an example i
recommend looking at almost any movie
targeted to teenage
girls that is about a bad boy the pure
loving
good girl heals the wounds of the
tortured bad boy trouble
what about the i mean that's just
rom-coms in general like the girl who
needs a man ultimately
because she's a mess like it's the same
kind of [ __ ] and he's there to fix her
it's all mirrors go both ways yeah yeah
rom-coms are just like that though i i
would say
that um humans all want someone to lean
on
and it's a lot nicer because sometimes
from a nurturing lady because my guy
friends has such rough hands
yeah and if i had to choose who to get
sexual pleasure from i would say my
girlfriend who i like a lot
there you go
[Laughter]
or guy with very soft hands which is abe
compared to abe but abe is the only
person
in the world that i would like a [ __ ]
from
yeah if it was a versus a girl that i'm
seeing
right now i'd be like girl that i'm
seeing right now abe
get out of here i just like that the
hand job is the key to like your
personal healing
yeah emotional trauma fill them with
hand-drawn can anybody have soft hands i
could get behind that one though
i like that one because i think my
personal experience i feel like
there's like a time when like i didn't
understand what it meant to even be a
partner
and then like i think i don't know why
but like girls seem to
get understand that like they're there
for their guy a lot but then like
vice versa we're not there for a woman
so then like i don't know like through
through time like you kind of taught me
how to be there for you so like
i can get behind i can get behind like
on a serious tip i think that the way
we what do you call it like back each
other up
is different like the way we do it is
different we're like trying to solve
problems logically but we're not
actually
there for them yeah yeah different
support systems emotional healing and
general
like not everyone guys jesus generally
speaking
generalizing we're generalizing don't
get offended well that's toxic behavior
i heard
i heard
but yeah so there's a few other ones i
think are pretty good if you guys want
to check them out
it's in the link in the description
you